foreign
[Music]
ER why he wants this job I need the
money money isn't the reason he wants
his job the salad man killed his son
you don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here to translate actually I'm here to
interpret John you have tallies
approaching
The Interpreter saved my life and now I
have to go save his Ahmed ended up with
a price on his head from the Taliban we
can't intervene I am gonna have to get
him out myself
I'm looking for Ahmed I'll give you a
full set of tools but you're gonna be
alone
you got to adapt this is what you got
I am going to get that man and his
family out
guy Richie's the Covenant rated R in
theaters April 21st
[Music]
for residents of element City
Air usually has their head in the cloud
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy
nothing weird going on here just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll it'll be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
[Music]
[Applause]
type squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left fire town sorry
buddy elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
doesn't anyone get to tell you what you
can do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
watch this
remember I see a change in you
what hair guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes
never once asked what I wanted to do
write this this ad those are too hot I
love
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you see he likes it
good evening forgot everything you think
you know what
everyone is raving about Dungeons and
Dragons It's the kind of Epic fun you've
been waiting for protect it with your
very life I will
all this none of us can say our lives
gone the way we'd hoped I did think
you'd serve longer we got an early
release
good behavior yeah baby good it charms
its way into your heart oh God to kiss
you try it
the most Chris Pine a Chris Pine
performance has been in a long time just
because that sentence is symmetrical
doesn't make it not nonsense a crowd
pleaser that actually pleases it's a
gift for everyone
all right take me down this is absurdly
high it's not what we discussed
anything you want to add
I'm good
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
only in theaters March 31st
Mr burnfield welcome
I am
you will make a very good assistant no
he's evil we will protect you you have
the word of the most trusted institution
on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
Grandville you're so purpose in life is
to serve me now let's see
I just want a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns your hero Robert Montague
Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me The
Dark One
others the Lord of death so you bring
and people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes cake no the Cape is dry
clean only strictly yeah I will wear
this it's fly yeah
I've got nothing such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering I will
Unleashed everyone you care about will
suffer because you betrayed me we have
to stop him Before Sunset
[Music]
I deserve happiness and I take full
charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is going to be my way worse it's my
least favorite part of the job
you're not here we're not there the car
exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
Farm Road 6 Mile 75.
stargazers and Space Cadets
here we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23rd 3007 BC
when the Arid Plains meteorite made
Earth impact
Campbell you're very good in the one
about the [__] in the brothel who gets
amnesia making a pediatrician you were
very honestly maybe my favorite
character ever I don't know why nobody
else liked it
[Music]
this is indicate what oh the beeps and
blips we don't know some of our
information about outer space May no
longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
foreign
like we're doomed
maybe we are I've just been born the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's the alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alien on Top Hat
what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct it's true
going so fast
[Music]
I do a nude scene you want to see it
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak
I had a vision
of people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
and I was doing it we won't let that
happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own body
are you ready to start your training the
Pegasus Knight is Brave
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
what the hell did you do that
the war that Oasis is unlike any other
before
[Music]
I think I wanted any of this
powers of liability once he learns to
control it no living man will be able to
stop
you might want to buckle up
though you were the only night in town
you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
why
Mr ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
Audrey I got you
[Music]
[Laughter]
cat lives there now your famous college
roommate are you ready to lose to a
celebrity
Dead Eye is coming by the way get out
your cousin hey Audrey oh hi hey where
did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
Ching okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see an American what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
[Music]
your drug dealers now [__]
we can't get caught with drugs in China
we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen you
know we can bypass airport security
K-pop Stars everyone remember their
names sassy cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't
believe these girls are singles girls
show them
um
you're a fan of cardi B right yeah but
is she here
there's some [__] in this house
there's some horse
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put an eight
just push pull I mean twice
my [__]
[Music]
come here
all right
[Music]
get over there
what is she
[Music]
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for me
I can't believe I'm never gonna speak
when I was just a little girl I asked my
mother what is this Danny
oh
will I be pretty
we're alive
to me
[Music]
don't want to take my babies
that's what happened to Paul
it happened too fast
[Music]
our Grace Terror through total chaos
thank you
please
[Music]
oh yeah yeah you know how to fight kids
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
foreign
what's up
whole night
begins
[Applause]
foreign
get up to the house
come on guys
happy we're gonna be late to the Royal
Wedding let's go get married what I mean
let's give Bridgette and Crystal married
yeah oh because it would be weird if we
got married yeah wow
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy come on Daddy I'm the cutest
Little Flower Man
we are gathered here today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
drama calling me
you're the guy from bro Zone we were
just listening to them
but that's all in the past
never told me you had a secret brother
correction used to be my brother
my brothers walked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets
Branch it's time we find the rest of our
brothers and get the band back together
bro we're gonna have the best family
reunion ever Frozone 2.0 Frozone reunion
rose on Here We Grow Again Frozone
where'd they grow I don't know we're
gonna find
[Music]
them tiny Bridge Poppy and random dude
on another Musical Adventure oh hey tiny
you see that button right there oh you
mean the button is taking every fiber
about being not depressed it
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing
huh look at that
[Music]
species of flowering plant native to
Eastern Asia
smell at certain times of the year gives
you a real Buzz
like the buzz you get
just before pulling the trigger
I have a favorite ask what is it my
grand niece
I would like you to take her home as an
apprentice
she dropped out of school and then she
ended up in a bad crowd
you'll learn how to garden
are you satisfied with the life that you
have
how would you ask that
you talk a lot of [__] but
just one thing you don't talk about
sad yourself
[Music]
there's not much to know
he puts a deep six on nine bad guys
that was a long time ago
if they're dead you're not forgotten
have you ever killed anyone
[Music]
why would you say that
take off your shirt
foreign
when I'm the Queen of Scotland
gardening is a belief in the future a
belief that things will happen according
to plan who did this to you what are you
gonna do
how to start a new life
I have created this life
filled it with rules
now seems the time to break one
[Music]
go
bro you're late
let them know you're here
let the fights begin why watch out
Roy get up you know you cost me a lot of
money tonight you got 48 hours to make
this up
you haven't heard from Roy we don't go
this long without hearing from him get a
little worried sometimes he's a vagabond
fighting people for scrap
we're about to load uncut diamonds into
your truck and you know what will happen
if this doesn't get the ball in the next
24 hours do you
got a brother right the one with a
beautiful wife and the two daughters
what does Jill have to do with this I
need collateral
yeah why not
[Music]
all right
[__] up I think that's the closest
did you get us into Roy 50 million in
diamonds
where's my diamonds three SUVs and some
guys robbed her hello
girls are gone the three of us are
getting my family back
set up sniper and cover us I'm in
position
make it to the top
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think the question in my
honor
Ranger Alex diary British intelligence
we're here with the approval of your
state department
I've been sent to ask you to go into
Mexico and collect a prisoner
we believe he is planning a terrorist
event in London
shame for his ranger I think I'd have
liked going up against you
we're gonna try to Spring him he's going
to launch a dirty bomb help me track him
now you've already talked to the major
Everton
right
you're in the UK now protocol is
everything
wouldn't you agree that that was quite
Reckless
two tabs in this game
it was on a run
I was doing the hunting
we've got their attention
the fortune in the favor is the Bold
good luck to your Rancher
what kind of story were you thinking
about how something to prison oh all
right and uh what about a prison
interests you jail
for sure
happy anniversary we're so lucky yeah so
Elliot tells me you're a writer and
you're the last one it should have done
better there's lots of new voices
refugees cancer murder abuse I'm an old
voice you're the best voice maybe if Dad
hadn't just been verbally abusive it
would have been a bestseller don't say
that
your Memoir is great your new book is
great how are you feeling a little off
my game the only reason she makes me a
salad is because she wants me to lose
weight which is passive aggressive I
want you to be healthy it doesn't matter
can you shut up and keep talking Don you
want to intervene here we can do this at
home Michael Milani looks tired
imagine what are you nuts you get BOTOX
well I just get a little bit right here
you know I can still move my eyebrows
watch watch
[Music]
it feels too late oh my God oh my God I
think I'm gonna throw it right what do I
got right here
no I don't think I can I can't
if I did say that you took it out of
context are you gonna fight me now
he's been lying to me this whole time I
wasn't lying I was encouraging that's
not true you were lying to be
encouraging you know what as an actor
Mark isn't always great so the times
when you don't think he's good what do
you send him you're so fantastic really
mom you're always expecting the best
from me you're welcome
[Music]
I just need to do something meaningful
what you do is is kind of meaningful
it's a who no one
world is falling apart and this is
what's consuming you well you're not
helping
I love you
oh okay well never mind
[Music]
we'll take it congratulations
oh this is nice
[Music]
breakfast
you seem happy
hi
oh hello sweetheart welcome to the
neighborhood I brought you something
it's a necklace it's very pretty
who gets a stranger something without
expecting something to return Mike this
is just some sweet old lady
please
mark
the house I don't like it
scared it's okay
I love you
[Music]
thank you